en allemagne de la hesse le vent de
liberté continue à souffler avec un
deuxième week-end d'ouverture du mur de
berlin une déclaration au journal
français l'humanité dimanche d'un
responsable du bureau politique de rda
indiquant que le parti n'a pas le
monopole du pouvoir dans le pays et puis
aussi une manifestation du parti
d'opposition est là et psych qui n'a pas
rencontré le succès escompté en raison
de la tentation du voyage à l'ouest
pendant le week-end des manifestants qui
avant d'évoquer leurs propres problèmes
ont tenu à montrer leur solidarité à
l'égard des tchèques qui ont manifesté
hier soit à prague die psych notre
envoyé spécial philippe rochot
50000 manifestants au pied du musée de
la finition demander la fin du
stalinisme des élections libres en rda
et dans les autres pays d'est ils
répondaient à l'appel du mouvement
d'opposition double au forum et non pas
comme pour les manifestations
traditionnelles du lundi en accord avec
l'église protestante
beaucoup d'habitants de la ville était
passée à l'ouest pour le week end mais
nouveau forum a pu compter ses
sympathisants et c'est une petite
victoire
solidarité d'abord avec les manifestants
de tchécoslovaquie contre la répression
à prague dix mille signatures
recueillies en quelques heures ici on
est fier de voir que c'est grâce à
l'action menée à l'intérieur de la rda
que les tchécoslovaques se sentent
aujourd'hui moins seul
il ya un parallèle entre la
tchécoslovaquie et la rda ce qui s'est
passé là-bas en 68 c'est un peu ce qui
s'est passé ici en 89 sauf que les
révolutions ne pourront plus être
réprimés aujourd'hui comme elles l'ont
été autrefois à prague les gens sont
prêts à aller très loin et ils n'ont pas
peur dassault de l'estrie la france n o
d'islande
mais les manifestants de leipzig ne
cachaient pas leur déception krenz
disette il n'apprend pas aux autres ce
que tu ne sais pas malgré les promesses
de réformes économiques les
sympathisants de nouveau forum veulent
encore aller plus loin